greetings to the checkin it's Monday the
2nd of October we're brought to you by
the freeze pipe let me talk to you guys
all right for the smoothest way to enjoy
cannabis you got to try a freezable
piece from the freeze pipe if you're
tired of inhaling har smoke having
coughing attacks and taking tiny little
rips then it's time for you to make a
switch you understand me listen for
years I smoked a bong with snow in it
when I lived in Colorado then I moved
away there was no more snow and boom the
freeze pipe shows up equipped with a
freezable glycerin chamber that cools
Smoke by over
300° you pop the chamber in the freezer
for an hour as the smoke passes through
it it instantly chilled for an ice cold
puff without the after bur without the
coughing this bong whatever you choose
will rock your world for me I put it in
the little thing whenever I'm ready to
smoke I also keep it very clean don't
mess around don't let it boil up or
whatever it'll the smoke comes out there
Le know the smoke comes out of there and
then I blow the chamber out and look
like the Fourth of July anyway check out
the newest pieces the mini
bong the tornado bong and the glycerin
blunt trip blunt tip to cool down J
joints
Blunts and Vapes no matter how you like
the smoke freeze pipe will make it ice
cold so do me a favor this company is
American-owned for over seven years and
affordably priced shop the smoothest
pipe bubblers bongs and more at the
freeze pipe.com use code Diaz D AZ for
10% off your entire order that's the
Freez pipe.com
Co Diaz for 10% off your entire order
and let me talk talk to you about
something people order now for the
holidays everybody's happy you grandma
wants to eat turkey grandma wants to
smoke a buong on Thanksgiving she's at
home watching soap opers in her little
half a coffin you made her bring
her the the freeze pipe and flip
her wig no more Bingo get her
out of the goddamn house this message is
brought to you by the freeze pipe.com
don't
forget Diaz Diz for 10% off your entire
order let's get this party started it's
Monday morning baby turn off your TVs
run for your lives it's over they didn't
put you on this planet just to give up
if all joy to do it I can rule the world
actually you got to be thinking welcome
back
[Music]
to
hello hello what's up hello you're I can
hear you what's up dog it's beautiful
Monday morning SE good to see October
October the ren D it is it's
unbelievable how fast this is going I I
I can't believe it myself some days but
who gives a what's happened my
little brother I was homaha
Nebraska dude it was one of the best
weekends of like my
comedy career and quotes now but it was
as good as advertised it was like even
even better like it was just what shows
correct five shows five shows look at
you five shows every show was really
good P all the shows were
packed the club
was awesome the crowds were awesome the
staff the staff and like I've heard
about Colleen who was amazing and like
super nice but like even the staff was
hysterical like there was I I don't want
I'm Not Gon to out anybody but there was
someone there who was very nice the
entire time like just very quiet and
very unassuming and at like one of the
last nights they came in and said if you
guys want to want to party and he throws
the this bag of homemade cookies on the
table and says these will knock your
dick in the dirt and it was one of the
funny like we were on mushrooms it was
one of the funniest moments in the in
the whole weekend and there were strong
cookies they were really
good huh did you bring any home no we
ate them all right you ate them all
right so you you mixed and matched on
Saturday night yeah oh yeah it was um
but it was so fun it was it was a great
weekend how were your
sets four out of five were really good
the fifth one it wasn't bad but I I
stumbled over my words a couple times
and I was unhappy about it but the like
Saturday
night it was one of the be like the
better weekends I've had let's talk
about Saturday nights real quick
uh it's crazy Lee the first
seven years you will come home every
Saturday night scratching your
head
because you did great
Thursday then you did great when you
went to Uncle Floyd's piano bar
and you did karaoke and you did 10
minutes of material then Friday you went
back to the
club and you did another two shows and
you did really well you even added some
material for The Late Show and then
Saturday you eat a bag of dick on
Saturday evening
early and then you die a even
worse Deb on Saturday night and you're
like what's going on with Saturdays for
about this will happen for about nine
months and
then you'll block you'll get out of that
block that you've put in front of
yourself and you'll start doing well
either
or what do you mean either or either or
you'll either do great the first show or
great the second show and then something
funny will happen on the way to dance
like it usually does with standup you'll
start because where you came from and
where where you people you were around
early on and what you heard in that
room you'll start saying you
know what I don't even like I won't even
with the early show on Saturday the
early show on Saturday and people were
coming in they're confused I'm going up
second they're still coming in they're
sitting down they don't know what they
want to drink there's a guy with three
eyes sitting one next to him and he
doesn't want to sit next to them the
waitress comes over there's so much
movement going on early game Saturday so
as a feature act you come out and that's
still unsettled we don't notice that at
the time but that's this is what's going
on that's why I don't like these seven a
clock shows because people gotta
cut off like a Chinese
dude to get to the show
you know who needs that who needs
that so I always liked eight and 10
or eight and nine for 45 the early show
it's people who have children they got a
babysitter maybe they're a little you
know maybe they with a sheet with a
little h m that don't e ass you know who
knows that the people who go to church
you come out there with a
off-color joke four minutes in that's
going to be the longest 26 minutes of
your life after that you'll
remember that forever you'll remember
that at so many moments of your life I
still do but then you start figuring out
that the Saturday show they're
drunk they've been sitting in the lobby
drinking they it's a college town they
were watching their game there's so many
variables to a comedy set and
what happens on a Saturday night
guy there's a UFC you bet Dustin
porier and he gets kicked in the head
you lost
$100,000 you know this it's a thousand
dilemas so and when I started the wasn't
social
media so right you do one of those sets
and like not comedy clubs but it's like
comedy companies and they have comedy
rooms for the weekend and every once in
a while they'll throw you a Friday and
Saturday you're gonna
die you're gonna die but they put you up
it's three days off your schedule you
don't have to worry about after the
death you'll never even go there again
when people talk about that city you'll
go look at I don't off the entire city
yeah like you're done I don't need to go
there tell people the
truth last time I went there I got
robbed you you won't tell people the
truth for about a
year oh and then one day you go do I ate
a bag of dicks what is wrong with me now
I gotta get back in there and now the
guy remembers you bombing so now he
doesn't really want to bring you
back and then after about a year and a
half Jimmy shuber calls
and he says I need a feature next
weekend and there you are again and this
time you destroy the room and whatever
happened four years earlier is
forgotten that is a bummer when you do
bad at like a show and you feel like a
Booker doesn't like you now how do you
get past
that think about it you're a Boston Red
Sox fan correct of course you know when
they pay $10 million for a season and
this guy shows up and he throws and
he strikes out all the time it's pretty
rough after that
season and then but there's so many
variables you can't ride a
off yeah maybe he's a bust out we all
can't be you know Shani Otani
whatever his goddamn
name it's definitely not
sh Show hey if we were all shy otanis
you know it wouldn't be fair right
so that's how I feel about that stuff so
never trip on your sets because it used
to destroy me like I used to do those
triple runs and he'd put you
back there in six months and you you
just got over that beating because the
night because you were leaving on a
Tuesday night and they said and you had
to get pick up the facts when you got to
the hotel sometimes he'd say to you Lee
you're going to go to Omaha Nebraska
Wednesday night and then from there
you're going to go to ogalala
Nebraska and then from there you're
going to go wherever the University of
Nebraska is and you're going to go okay
he goes just for right now get to the
hotel in the first place I said Omaha
Nebraska it's a holiday in you're
working with the guy Joey deers watch
him watch him do not lend him
money do not do drugs and avoid him and
uh will send the
facts of the remaining rooms to you to
the hotel where you're staying at wow
that's yeah so you jump in your car you
put on the seven hours you get there
there's four sheets of where you going
every night radio the hotel you're
staying at who you're checking in with
you go upstairs to your room you look at
the one for that night you review
it it tells you you look at the one for
the next next night because you want to
see what time you got to leave the next
morning you can't be snorting coke and
doing karaoke with with waitresses if
you got to get up at 4 in the
morning and drive like sometimes when I
saw that I would pack my bags go
do the comedy show just get in the car
afterward because you're not gonna sleep
anyways yeah I'm not gonna sleep so I
would pick up five six hours on the road
take a 2hour nap drive another two or
three hours get to the hotel at
lunchtime and sleep all day get up for
an hour write some jokes but there was
also always a line in there that said by
the way when you get to this room you're
not allowed to say any curse words it's
a Mormon room so for a guy like me
seeing that at the fouryear level I
can't cover that spread I gotta throw in
a couple in there you know what
I'm saying did you ever get
fired
yes what is that that that sounds crazy
to
me it's not as crazy as you might think
I got F I'm a trif factor type of
I got fired from Comedy
Club I got fired from a a TV show set
one time I had to leave with security
with oh holy and then uh that was
it that was it which which one do you
want to tell
first I can't tell the comedy club one
because I don't what club it was it was
so it was like it had to be
95 how bad do you have to bomb and get
fired like no we didn't bomb and got
fired we did a
room myself and another
comic who this comic was
great I was already at the comedy
store and this guy we call
headlined
a comedy club in West
Virginia it was a week of one nighters
this guy was burying me late he was
featuring for you huh was he featuring
for you no no no we were co-headlining
co-headlining sorry he was just buring
my ass you
know and uh we got along he was a great
guy but my pomy was the real deal holy
feel when it came to women I would go to
my hotel room and I get a call from his
wife you know where he is I've been
calling this room 80 times and I'm like
I'm trying to snor Coke and whack off to
whatever movie there is on this
hotel calling me from that owns the
hotel I got now you call I swear to God
every night my phone would ring
at one time of the night from his wife
Jesus ask you know so he was just a plan
then like Friday night he caused some
damage and the wife was involved she
showed up and he had his other of many
women there and we got fired I woke up
that Saturday morning and they said you
got to go and it's funny you mentioned
that because I was thinking about that
this week the guy who you
were with where he would have
been right now today he would have been
one of the top
comics what do you think held him
back uh eating
how's about that for you how was
your week beside that
Tarzan my week was pretty great my
week was honestly just focused on on
Omaha to be honest that's what happens
you put everything into it you look at
your tapes you listen to tapes you put
your p's and q's and you move the
on we had a good week finally the writer
strike is over I'm very happy huh why
why are you happy about that because
hopefully I could do something with the
book tremendous oh perfect okay that's
awesome option you know so with some
luck uh hopefully we could option it and
start some talks for a TV show or series
whatever the they want to do you
know the actors aren't going to go back
for a few
weeks so that'll give the writers some
time to write their new stuff I
hope they don't come back with you know
galaxy of the Guardians whatever that
is and I gotta put up with those
things I watch them with my daughter I
don't know how they do it they shoot
those movies like in three weeks you
think so I I I don't know but nothing is
real you just stand there next thing you
know you're in Galactica
Ville a little chubby Mexican
dude and Ms the next thing you
know you fight you know the the the
Illusions whatever the the makeup I
don't know I don't know you know this is
why I enjoy those movies with her right
to see her get a tickle out of them but
I also try to mingle other in there
so she knows reality the out how to
watch in the front French Connection she
didn't a great movie she didn't dig
it 60s movie what's that isn't that like
a 60s movie 70s 70s movie early
70s pretty good movie high intensity as
a matter of fact the guy who directed
that directed The Exorcist rest his soul
whatever freak in that freak but
he's somewhere better now
anyway that the writer strike went back
uh I had some meetings this week that
were pretty good you know I feel
a lot better my family's great I just
left a double
header oh for basketball or
softball no it's softball season
she has two games tonight so
I went to the first game and that's
awesome I don't know if they won or loss
there was a lot of hits and a lot of
walks uh she was in the they
playing Staten Island they were a little
better of a team they were more coach
coached a lot better but I got the watch
the first game I got to watch the
warm-up there was a DJ there today you
know she like you're there
now yes listen I like to be there when
I'm there there's no other place I'd
rather be I'm watching them play
softball which I never thought I'd watch
you know I may have some medibles in me
mixing I got the off to keep the flies
away and I'm catching flies at the same
time you know I'm having a great time
I'm blowing the whistle whenever Mercy's
pitching to get the focus
so she knows I'm in the thing that's how
we talk secretly you follow what I'm
saying I learned that from the Houston
Astros you got signals they were banging
the garbage bags over in Chicago yeah
steing signs you gotta do little things
I'm not stealing signs but I try to
focus her like if she throws too high
whatever but who gives a half the
people watch this don't want to hear
about my daughter was a I
don't know I think they do but I to the
movies the other night what what do you
see my friends had a big dinner at
leforte in akac it's a new restaurant my
buddy opened up tremendous food
and me and a bunch of guys from high
school were gonna go prend like
Wednesday my daughter throws a bomb on
me I said I told my wife listen toor I'm
G to meet these guys she goes wait a
second and mercy was like pale she goes
you didn't remember we're going to see
dumb
money and I'm like okay I felt bad she
goes it's at
7:00 so I said perfect I'll take you to
MMA we'll come home we'll shower and
then I'll shoot you over to King's
Chinese restaurant where I took the menu
picture yeah perfect she got the steak
on a stick I went light I got the shrimp
and garlic with the white rice kept it
really light we got out of there we got
can't believe you didn't get the
dumplings what's that I can't believe
you didn't get the dumplings dog I gotta
watch it I'm and I tell you what when I
have those meals that are rich now I'm
done I'm done it's over I'm a different
billy goat you know what I'm
saying I can still eat snots and
but I gotta watch my meals you follow
I'm saying are you still eating your
snots from time to
time oh not as much because I don't
produce as much I'm not snorting coke I
still got the little Nest that comes out
over here and I wiggle it every once in
a while and sometimes you get a good one
sometimes you don't sometimes you get a
little speck you throw it up in the air
but sometimes you rip out like a little
vein like a six incher and play with it
for a little while and then you just
inhale it like a like a oyster
you know what I'm
saying truthless
one oh my God Jesus Christ Joey what do
you want you told me this is the
checking Lee this is not about you know
this is us talking what you know
whatever they want to do they got to do
we a
lies that was it last week you told me
you eat gum
still yeah what happened let me tell you
something let's talk about last week for
starters just to to get this party
listen hold on one second how about a
word for my
sponsor this episode is brought to you
by better help sometimes you're lacking
the motivation to do things you should
do and your self- sabotage yourself
let's talk about this therapy can help
you figure out what's holding your back
so you can stop working against yourself
better helps online therapy is
incredible but you could talk to a
licensed therapist through video chat or
by phone or even by message getting the
help you need has never been easier when
I moved I had some struggles I was stuck
I contacted better help here I am three
years later throwing in heat take a
quick quiz to get match with a licensed
therapist if you ever need to switch
therapist for any reason you could
change at any time for no additional
charge no questions asked so do me a
favor the holidays are coming you want
to have a clear head make your brain
your friend with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz Diaz and I'm Gonna Get You 10% off
your first month it's going to help you
out if it helped me and you know I got
problems it'll help you that's better
help h lpom
/dz betterhelp.com
Diaz and now we're going back to talk
some more whatever the hell we were
talking about all right so don't forget
visit better help get your act together
Focus before the holidays you want your
parents to invite you back to the house
for dinner you know what I'm saying
anyway what were we talking about we're
talking about last Monday last Monday
you and I decided to do the Edibles a
lot
earlier correct yes I did the same thing
I did last last Monday I uh did not
respect I didn't know what my tolerance
was and I think I opened up with maybe
three of them right I blasted those at
like
five and
then during the podcast I must have been
popping them or like at seven I popped
like two more let me tell you something
my friend when I had it when I wrapped
up I already knew I had to do that fox
show yeah the Jesse Walters whatever his
name is so you know they just called at
5:30 and wanted me to drive into
the city I'm very grateful they thought
about me thank God it was a subject that
I kind of knew about they tried to go a
little political on Uncle Joey and
that's what I tapped out but there was
more to the story see because I'm
sitting here with you and they're
texting me telling me they're outside oh
damn so already I ended the podcast with
you I basically got up
drank some water and went outside right
into this little CIA van as I'm
going in there I'm like what am I doing
I gotta go inside and get a gun or
something because where am I these guys
might be Cubans they might be taking me
to the airport those were the
Edibles that were hitting me dog trust
me and I got getting paranoid what you
were getting paranoid something was
going on like my mind was just racing so
I got into the uh van there was
one sweet kid shook my hand what's going
on I sat down and as I'm sitting there
in the van like this remember it's a
van Le I got a room in here okay
this this's a van I'm sitting
there and all sudden the Edibles start
percolating to the point where I had to
tilt my head back so I could see the
eyeballs would I was hearing
Spanish
people I was hearing AFR Cuban music it
was on and now they made me put the
earphones on and I'm sitting there like
a moo they told me to run out and now
they got me in there and they're like
you're probably gonna go on about nine
o'clock I listen I ain't gonna make it
till nine o'clock
I and that dude's face froze he's like
okay we'll get you out of here in about
six minutes after the commercial break
by the time they hit me with the
camera in the question I was in
Gaga Ville I blacked out that
night I blacked out on Edibles
yeah I blacked out I don't know what
happened on TV or
later oh not on TV later like two hours
later the Edibles met up with the
mushroom and got
deep so all I remember is going to bed
and waking up my wife telling me a bunch
of things you don't remember being
downstairs and talking about this movie
for like 20 minutes I I don't remember
dick Jesus I went deep in the murky was
how often do you black out that come on
I haven't blacked out in 20
years when I was eating
Quaaludes I that was even 40 years ago
why you you know who blacks the out
on those and but maybe I don't know
I was doing bong hits you know it was a
rough week who the knows the next
day I got up and I went right to the red
light therapy and I swe that muongo
juice out I love sweating in there for
34 minutes and then I walk out I sit in
the air condition I dry up I put my
clothes on then I open up that door and
I smell in there
oh oh the red light therapy yeah with
the heat it's 154 degrees in there for
34 minutes I take a a 30 second break I
step out and drink some liquid
IV with some cholesterol in that
which is TI protein when
you're born it gives you extra strength
anyway we're not getting into that right
now I'm not a doctor I'm just a
player you know what I'm saying and and
what does that smell like what's that
you said the the smell of the red light
therapy oh when I come out it it's not
the red light therapy it's the water
that comes out of me Le oh no yeah you
it smells like straight up ABX
capsules eggs and Freddy's
pork fried
rice
damn beautiful you're not high anymore
like you know how you're not high the
next
day when I wake
up after the red light therapy one cup
of coffee sweat it all out you know I
try to move around I go to the gym I go
to I went back to Jiu-Jitsu last week I
was ecstatic about that I
finally got to go in there and see the
guys and make it happen you know
that's it awesome how'd it go it went
great I'm gonna hit I'm gonna hit this
week twice I'm GNA try to hit this week
twice I got to do a couple things I went
up to my neighborhood the other day it's
been raining here for a week and
a half straight every day is like Land
of Confusion you don't know when you're
gonna get the call about the canceled
softball practice the canceled game you
know so we were just playing you know we
try to get it MMA we try to get him you
know involved in but it's been
brutal so sadly I said this
early I filled up my car and I went up
north what did you do up there I went up
the what do you think I went up
there I went over and took pictures of
the George Bridge
because I went to Rudy's my
friend oh should you get the Kari huh
you get the calamari yeah half order
with shrimp and calamari I had the salad
the house salad the full
order a nice cup of Rhode Island
Seafood
Chow
Jesus then I got I drove down Bergen
Line Avenue my old little
haunts I drove down into North Bergen to
visit my friend's ex-wife she's a very
sweet lady I I called her she didn't
answer so I didn't think she was home I
went over to Bergen Line Avenue to see
my buddy who owns the jewelry store and
that's impossible you're not going to
get parking anywhere that's just
impossible I mean I was at a light it
changed eight times oh that
kills me by that time I was like I gotta
go I don't have just pay I I gave it a
New York try I should have gone up like
how my plan was to go up on a Tuesday go
up on a Thursday Tuesday is even better
if I get up there and get it out of the
way I can leave here at 9:30 get up
there at 10:30 find parking go see him
swing over pick up a couple Cuban
sandwiches some Bakery products and
make a U-turn South you won't
even know I was there the only know him
there is the Easy Pass bing bing it
doing 90 you know what I'm
saying it was too busy on a Saturday
it's too much all those Spanish people
out getting the best deals they need the
avocados God knows what else you know
but speaking of that rain in New York
did you see the flooding that's going on
in New York in like the subway and
listen guys this this was everywhere
this was I I don't know I don't know
what happened last week I don't know if
we're getting the message I don't know
if this has become Seattle New Jersey I
don't know but hold on one second so I
went to Union City from there I said you
know what it's time to go home I
got back on keny Boulevard and I shot no
I dog you couldn't make a left up right
onto Bergen line till I got down to like
the 39th Street and I knew that
area so I finally made it right there
and I crossed Kennedy Boulevard I shot
down to Bergen Turnpike there I drove
past my mother's
Cemetery dog they haven't mowed the lawn
in about a month in that
or it rained so much that
they grass grew that much but there were
two spots where somebody hit the
fence with a car and it's still bent
over like you could just walk up the
fence and jump the and then I went
down to my own neighborhood and it's
like they just suck the energy
out of
there how they do that I don't know
first off it looks like it's a war zone
my corner my ex corner there where I
would hang out and grow up and giveing
that Terrace there's two houses on the
corner as you drive by you go what the
is that there's like growing
on the
buildings I don't know I don't know it's
weird when you go to where you grew up
and you expect to see something but the
park is very nice they did a great job
with the park but they built everywhere
the woods were when we grew up that was
our that was our little camping
territory but nobody had a tent you know
what I'm saying we just went up there
and did all the you're not supposed
to do at home people would drop Playboys
up there you'd see all condoms and you
pick them up with a stick you talk
somebody to
sniff gave somebody a small $2 in a
bottle of Budweiser a nip don't
do anything and they and they tore it
all down no it's all developed
up there right building them on front of
the buildings they built some other
and you're like I used to walk through
there to cut up the shop
right I would walk up through there and
there'd be 10 kids walking through there
because their mother sent them to
shop right so we cut behind the
pool hall and then walk up the
shop right there is it depressing that
they change it that shop right where I
used to go as a kid yeah they could turn
that into a haunted place it's still
there I went to shop right about a mile
from my house it's a 20123 shop right
holy lights self checkout
self checkout if you have a card self
checkout if you have cash self checkout
if you're on welfare whatever the
you're showing up with they're taking it
from you you know what I'm saying they
don't give a
they a special line just for
welfare what's that they have a special
line just for people in welfare they'll
take International money they don't give
a they cash it right there little
arrow comes out with a suitcase hand
around his wrist and they open it right
there what do you got money from Belgium
Honduras we you got it we take it we
take it exra two point viig because
we're right here in the middle of the
supermarket we not going to ask you for
an
ID thank God because obviously you're
gonna spend the money in a
Supermarket I don't know I'm just making
this up I don't know what they do
anymore but it was very nice compared to
what I expected to walk in there to see
it was beautiful clean as
people everywhere helping you can I help
you can I help you very high
level how does it make you feel to see
the like the
changes it makes me feel very are you
crazy I don't know how I feel as
long as they get me out of there as fast
as possible no not not at Shop Right in
North BG makes me feel emotional you
know discussing with my
therapist maybe uh you were attached to
that shop right crazy it makes
me feel
like time has moved on it's over that
was then this is now all I got to worry
about is what's in my circle you
know what I'm saying speaking of which
we're coming out a little early with you
so I took a bat
today was 50 bucks you know when I say a
bat you know me and I and I knew my
was off I took Miami because I was going
to florentines out of respect they were
getting two and a half that line was
whack if you bet Miami today you're
whack I just threw the small 20
just to watch the game and I had
Cleveland against uh Baltimore
Baltimore I thought Deshawn Wilson was
going to throw 20 touchdowns
obviously he hurt his shoulder you know
trying to do a reach around around the
little Chinese masseuse you know
that attack there's a masseuse with a
story in Cleveland from last night
anyway let's drop a little DraftKings
love on you we'll be right
back give us some minute hit it we're
back listen how many times I got to
bother you people the NFL season is
going strong draft King sports book is
hooking new customers up right now with
an offer that's too good to be true I
know you heard it but now you're GNA
hear from Uncle Joey bet $5 on any game
this week to score 200 instantly in
bonus bets all customers could take
advantage of the sweeten the offer every
game day this October you guys know me
dog I just told you I lost this weekend
what the hell I lost Sunday but I had a
great time I had some action this
weekend I went over to a party listen
it's the DraftKings is the best way to
make the big game even more ex anxiety
who's better than you guys getting on
the game day greatness download the
draftking Sportsbook app now use code
Joey J OE y new customers stop it you
could score 200 instantly in bonus bets
when you bet just $5 on the NFL period
That's Co Joey Jo OE y only a draftking
sports book an official sports betting
partner of the NFL the crown is yours
tonight what's happening tonight you got
a great game I think the Giants are
playing somebody I don't know who the
line is but who cares download the
DraftKings app right now and let's get
Monday start it next week is Columbus
Day and you want a little Gus in your
pocket at least you'll have some bonus
bets if nobody invites you to a Columbus
Day party or whatever the hell it is
anyway thank you for
listening we're back all day you're
expecting phone calls you know who call
nobody start everybody wants to be your
friend get the out of here
you know yesterday I called three people
something they all called like eight
hours later nobody got I didn't pick it
up for nobody like I I don't even know
what I called you for anymore my sister
keeps calling what' you call me for what
you I don't know call me on Tuesday
maybe I'll Remember by then I'm getting
old I don't need this either pick
up the phone or call me tomorrow
because by that time I'll uh get my head
together you know what I'm saying I love
it it's goodly I got no
complaints yeah know what do you want me
to do I'm doing the best I can I
love doing this with you this is the
best I can do for right now you know
what I'm saying oh I'm having a blast
dude yeah this is all you need to do
hopefully you come down and we'll set up
a little live show
somewhere oh I would love that go deep
give away some Malia sticks and
I've been liking I I I've been liking
doing the uh the like the mushroom late
shows with Josh like those are I like
it's
been like I used I was scared of them
when we were doing the
church like I was like Janu scared of
doing mushrooms by the way for the
people who are concerned about my uh
first of all I found that online I found
that one of the listeners that had yeast
infection in my ear oh I went to
CVS and I bought that little yeast
medicine I think little Q-tip and I put
it in there you know what my ears are a
little bit moisturized
more uh but they still smell like donkey
dick every once in a while that
juice that comes out of there is the
worst
I am so embarrassed about it but I
addressed the issue so thank you very
much you know what I'm saying as you
could tell I'm looking very uh
very uh I don't know anyway what were we
saying Ty I was just talking about doing
doing
mushrooms listen Lee I'm a I'm a big fan
of what you're doing I admire
the ball sack on
you
uh it's so funny you know
let's you know Point Blank I got into
comedy after I read that book by
that knucklehead Jewish junkie
whatever his name is you know at the
time I was out of prison and it
just sold me on what I thought I wanted
to do I knew I was a dead and goner and
I said it what's the guy I'm
talking about live from Carnegie Hall
the album I
have uh Lenny Bruce Lenny
Bruce so you know listen when I got into
comedy I remember I got into comedy in
June all right
and I kept getting froggy and froggy you
know I would smoke dope and then I would
stop you know I would like how can I
during the contest I didn't do any
drugs any drugs I took that contest very
seriously I had ruined
everything in my life I'm not
going to keep ruining it I would go in
there sober as a judge and after
whatever happen happen I'd have a few
Margaritas I'd get a package and
i' do what I have to do I'm not going to
tell you I was a saint here but
I started experimenting like after three
or four months we start taking chances
and the biggest worst thing I ever did
was eight months in trying to do
blow on stage yeah and I was the first
guy to go
up and I remember that I always
struggled at other shows when I went up
first and knowing that I said you know
what I'm not going to wear a suit that's
the other decision I made that night I'm
not going to wear a suit no more it's
not getting me nowhere the only thing
I'm doing is dropping 12 a week on dry
cleaning you know and I spill it and it
smells like dick and there's cocaine in
the pockets what am I wearing a
suit for every week that was the first
week I have dressed like a shirt
pair of jeans sneakers and I got a
package for the headliner and he gave me
like a quarter gram and I did like two
lines and I
uh went and got on
stage that was not a good
situation for me that night what what
did it feel like it felt really
bad
guys it did not feel good on stage I
knew I didn't have any control and I
never tried it again that's how bad I
felt on stage like I all my life I've
been doing this dumb and now I'm
going to bring it into my comedy shame
on you so St Patty's Day 92 never again
on stage then I started around
after the 10y year mark doing it the
night before a show and if you don't
think it hit it hurt me my performance
like if I got high on a Thursday night
if you want me to sit here and tell you
it didn't hurt my performance on a
Friday shame on
me
but that's a complete different thing I
know you don't drink alcohol you're very
focused on what's going on and I'm very
surprised that you're doing mushrooms
and I'll tell you
why I would have gave you mushrooms
three years ago and there's a certain
reason with
you you're uh Jewish and you're neurotic
and I always told you and I was kid and
Josh when we did the zoom call last
night I wasn't offing you in no way I
always saw you as a Woody Allen type
writer without you know marrying some
Chinese
kid I always saw you in that realm I
really did once you started doing comedy
I was very shocked what I saw came
up I know that every once in a while you
want to work hard rated or whatever but
you were always very tight and we'll go
back
to you know tonight I blew a whistle at
my daughter's game
right right when she was on pitching and
then I blew another one before she was
batting double header she goes dad do me
a favor don't distract me with
the
whistle you gonna do if you keep doing
this once you go to play in Newark what
do you think those girls are gonna be
doing they're gonna be throwing chairs
at you and you're up there pitching or
playing Third Base what do you think you
do a whistle is going to really
distract you you know what I'm
saying and uh but you need that that's
how you grow sometimes and since day one
and you could be honest you know I don't
give a who knows whenever we did
comedy at the Ice House my job was to
you
up oh that job was
because you had too much of a stick up
your ass to do comedy you had all the
tools except you were scared to cross
that line when you came into the office
office that day and what I always loved
about you was your comedy honesty
everybody kills everybody kills every
night right at the two threee Mark but
they're sitting right next to you paying
for a $ five
spot right and they bomb the last three
times you saw but their friend got him a
spot at the Irvine Improv and they
destroyed they got a standing ovation
you know no you came home and said the
I had a great time but the guy
brought me up as Lee
SWAT my insides crumbled up you know
what I'm saying it was like and I got
that that happened to me a thousand
times I laughed because wow I forgot
what it happened to me like you reminded
me of all this I went through and I
would giggle because I'd forget how I
reacted to it are you with me 100% so
you know it's uh it's funny when you
tell me those things
so when now you're doing
mushrooms before a show on
Saturday night late if you called me and
said you bombed I would never be angry
at you well we sometimes do it right
before I go on stage this it's not I'm
not I'm not like Theo who did it on the
church and then went to the Improv I
haven't I've done shows with you on
Edibles a million times I haven't felt
the mushrooms on stage that would be but
it is we do it like right before either
right before I go on or right after but
it's
been I don't and Josh would never make
me do it I don't think like I don't feel
like he like if I said no he wouldn't
give me
but I'm trying to be like I don't
know yeah exactly I want you to
understand one thing in comedy one in
Rome number one look at who you're
with and they've always shown love for
you then out to throw you out of the
game in fact it's going to be a
different experience for you you might
even say to me you know next time I go
to La I'm gonna eat mushrooms because
I'm more freeer whatever the
whatever makes you free I don't give a
look at these people they do pounds
of steroids and they walk up to
you I train every day knock it off knock
it off why you embarrassing you know
what I'm saying with this this is
the same
thing I think I
couldn't listen the first two weeks of
this podcast or the second week we did a
podcast and we took it for granted and
we were a little stiff I'm stiff when I
do these things I know in my mind I
don't want to drink alcohol like it just
doesn't taste good so I got to drop an
edible or two but I got to make it hit
me but then I gotta eat one when I'm
here so it hits me all at one time and
I'm on shock when I'm here and I got to
make my mind work double fast I enjoy
that I enjoy being loose I'm better
when I'm loose anybody when they do
comedy if it if you go on stage with a
beer in your hand and that makes you
feel loose I would never be angry at you
but don't force it if you're not a
drinker Don't Force It bring up water or
whatever stay hydrated you know the
commercials I don't have to tell
you here
but you know Paul Mooney used to go up
there with a bottle of champagne Cat
Williams you know and I know they Joey
that was later on but I don't give a
I don't bring I don't give a
if you bring a teddy bear up there as
long as you feel
comfortable whatever takes that
stiffness away from you so be it again
I'm not adhering to Aderall I've never
even done that I'm not adhering to
a shot of blow I'm not adhering to
heroin but I would be a hypocrite if I
sat here and said to
you what listen I want you to
kill my goal is you to
kill you think I'm mad at Le Zeppelin
for being heroin Junkies you think I'm
mad Sabbath for being cocaine junkies it
worked for them it work and they have
trials and tribulations from them and
they went on to do great things
you know I'm not advocating drugs here
I'm just saying that some people need
alcohol listen when I move to LA
I didn't want to fail so I wanted to
focus so what did I do I went on a
little Co I was broke I'm not going to
liy it's not like I gave up cocaine no
you
know things were bad I'm making 15 a
spot here and I started smoking
cigarettes to get the same
effect it was a euphoric effect and Josh
Wolf started very light like I I said
there wasn't much money so it was $2 a
piece we go to 7-Eleven on
kerson and we buy a pack of camel lights
or maror lights we always
alternated we'd go to where we had to do
comedy at we when we got home we throw
away whatever's left in the box that's
how it started for me it really started
at the tail end the
Seattle I noticed that a lot of comics
were smokers at this time if you were a
smoker and you got in the car with me
and lit a cigarette I throw you out of
the car if you told me that you
were going to drive me to a gig and I
got in your car and there was an ashtray
with cigarettes I'd have to get out but
at 33 years old something from watching
other Comics then I started studying
tape and a lot of them were smoking on
stage and it was the guys I liked so I I
tried it and I enjoyed it I
enjoyed smoking before stage I never
brought a cigarette on
stage well isn't nicotine like good for
Focus like do you feel like it
like what am I you know I don't know Dr
Phil I don't know if nicotine's
good for Focus I know for me it was
working you know I remember having a
conversation with you about
coffee you don't like coffee well guess
what I was raised in the Cuban
house where they make coffee with milk
it and they give you a piece of bread
with butter on it that is the nastiest
thing I've ever seen in my life
so at a certain age even though I
enjoyed the smell of coffee I did not
drink coffee ask me when I started
drinking coffee again when
2000 wow was 37 years old I didn't touch
coffee when the time I was 13
till I was 37 years old ask me why why
why
comedy I I started enjoying a cup of
coffee before show with the
cigarette I thought that was the most
euphoric thing in the world and if you
put a joint in that mix I'd go
to 7-Eleven you know I was making
headliner starter money 800 a weekend I
would go to a 7-Eleven and get a cup of
that Brazilian bold or whatever that
coffee was nicotine plus
whatever the they had Premium Plus
fill it up with that sugar that
uh whatever that cancer sugar I'd buy a
pack of cigarette I'd have some reefer
that to me was the most euphoric thing I
could do before I went on
stage it just Ros me up it didn't get me
too hyped up because sometimes you eat a
mushroom and it's before you get on
stage you're like yeah you know I'm
Jimmy Hendricks and then when you get on
stage the lights the people your heart
starts beating now it becomes something
completely different how do you
there with the mushrooms
well what what I was thinking about what
you were saying about the
weed I because I was like I up until
like six months
ago maybe a little bit more I was like
very
nervous like almost deil debilitating
before I would go on stage like at
PACE and I think the
weed I don't really smoke Much Anymore
before but if I would get a little high
I'd be very
relaxed and I think
now like you don't smoke cigarettes
anymore like I think that was a good
thing for me
to get over my anxious and my
anxiety I just I I I've had bad sets
high on stage like one of the uh Sony
Hall
ones I took an edible in the car on the
way there and then an edible on
stage and I just freeze oh yeah
fck I've been there you saw me one time
where I had a ask the waiter for a
chicken sandwich before I was going on
stage because I
milligrams uh whatever and guys I was
eating edibles but
the excitement of the show the
excitement that you have the adrenaline
once the adrenaline mixes with that
THC that's a weird feeling sometimes and
sometimes you got to adjust yourself you
gotta like ask questions who's in the
Army you know what I'm saying just just
to get your head back together who's
think gonna join the
Marines just to get your head back
together it's like getting punched in
the head you're going to step
back for a little you're going to
breathe a little bit you're going to see
who where the you are and you're
going to keep going I mean you
can't call a timeout when you walk on
stage yeah I was thinking about that
this week is
like because I had that show where I
stumbled and I like i' I've blanked too
like do you ever like address it with
the crowd just say oh I I I lost my spot
or or do you just blaze right through it
you get to a point where you
just tell the audience what you feel and
they'll take the ride of you because
they feel the honesty but it takes a
long time to get
there like it takes a long time to go
guys you never want to go in there with
a a guys I I got into a car
accident before I got I to hear that
you shouldn't have shown up you
would have waited for the attorney you
could have made some money with
Sullivan McGee whatever one of these
guys would have showed up with a
hospital bed you rushed over here you
understand it's like when a Fighter
fights he loses and a week later I got
an injury in Camp a week before come on
man don't even bring it up it maybe it's
true but don't say it don't say that
it's like and this is what I want from
Comics young Comics to don't blame
things the quicker you realize to blame
yourself and look at your faults and
listen to the tape the quicker you you
know the world ain't built around you
you're not doing something correctly
it'll take you a while to adjust and
you'll get it we all get it what
do you think we all just went up there
and blew bubbles out of your and
people were giggling and stop it
stop it that's part of the fun
that's the fun of
it that every night is
different you know sit at home every
night and they got to get up in the
morning and go to work and they're like
I got nothing going on in my life we get
to do something different every
night we get to look at somebody go ma
the show starts at 8 the show ends at
10:00 I'll be home about 10:30 and at
10:30 you're talking to two
sters from France that got a pound of
coke and you know a mini skirt on where
you going you better call that job and
tell them you ain't showing up tomorrow
and you're at a bar in
Worcester I mean I'm not saying I hooked
up I'm not saying that but I'm saying
there's so many it it opens up these
Adventures for for you next thing you
know you come to me with talking I'm an
open mic or you're an open mic but guess
what I got my own apartment I work for
an insurance company I make some money
you want to come over and watch the game
and me you and a couple Comics come over
there we watch the game and we each talk
about each other's Journeys you
know
whatever a lot of but there's also we
had someone try to get into the Green
Room this weekend we
had and then I was thinking about it do
you ever have
like it might have been a girl might not
have been a girl but like you you bring
someone to a show and they go crazy
because it reminded me of a story that
happened to me in San
Diego did I ever bring a girl to a show
when she went CRA or anybody like yeah
no I don't
know no my wife not the girl I mov to
laay
with no no I've been very for
man I heard horror stories about a dear
friend of mine who was working on a TV
show a Big Time TV
show and he invited his wife to one of
the
functions and his wife qued one of the
other actresses and was
like you know when you made out with him
did you use your tongue you know and
they had scor her out of there and
like that so you got to know the animal
you're dealing with and know how
they're going react
to alcohol around other people and know
how they were going to react to stardom
and people of a different realm that
they're never
around so I'm very fortunate about that
even the girl that I moved to LA with
dog we still talk and she's
still very supportive she calls me she
goes I found posters from Seattle and
pictures I'm going to scan them and send
them to you it's it's I've always had
people around me that were very
supportive especially when it came to
women you know my friends in the
business were all women we all supported
each other one way or another you're not
Jo getting into the business to sleep
with comedian girls you're getting into
the business to make them your
allies you know you help them they help
you you're on the road you bump into
them they don't listen I'm at the
hotel around the corner I'm over
here two blocks away if you need me I'll
call you after my show you call me after
another next day you having breakfast
the next day her manager is telling her
that you know he wants to talk to you
about management you have no idea the
possibilities meanwhile Joe Schmo is
trying to get into her pants why do that
that's what everybody's
doing that's
I I never like the the one with me and I
like Jim Pine he's a a door guy at matad
house or he's a comic but
he I met a girl at a bar and she asked
to come to the show with me this was
when I was 300 plus pounds and it was as
soon as we got there she started
heckling every comic like every comic
and Jim told me to leave and apparently
after the show she got on stage and
started yelling into the
mic it was the only and then it remind
it reminded me last night cuz this girl
just this lady was very nice but she
just got too drunk and tried to get in
the green room I'm and what she want to
do she want to swap Spit with you I
don't think so not me oh she was de to
see Josh Wolfie probably probably
Jake listen it
happens you know when you go to a a
smaller city they're very excited you
know I mean
I saw somebody the other day almost
crashed that car why because they wanted
to say hello to me oh Jesus and then
they left the ass of the car out and
they ran across the street to take a
picture her and her son it was
like and people were beeping at her and
I'm standing there like I don't know
what's going on I don't know these
people and then they started going
around and I may believe I don't know
what was going on a friend of mine
pulled up behind that's what really
happened that my friend saw what was
going on he was driving by and he pulled
up behind
him you got to love this little
tat from yesterday
so I'm about to go eat some lunch I
figured let me get out of the
neighborhood let me go up North and do
something different the girls were
somewhere and I wasn't going to see him
till 7 but we're going to drop her off
at MMA it was movie night and water
pistol night
down her and her girlfriends so me and
my wife had plans anyway so I was going
to meet my wife here about
4:30 I go up there I go let me grab some
lunch boom I go uh as I pull into I
parked three things away I put a
dollar in the meter and quarters I'm
walking into Rudy's and all
sudden this thing goes down I hear the
lady pull up but right there my buddy
pulls up behind her a kid I grew
up with who I love deily and she comes
over takes the picture and I go bro you
going to come in and he goes yeah yeah
I'll be in let me part and right there
two other dudes came over and I took
pictures with them two little Spanish
dudes we talked for like a minute I went
into the restaurant I had to pee like a
I just drove for 50
minutes all right I had I gotta pee went
in I peed I washed my hands you know I
got it together and I sat down and all
of a sudden you know you don't have to
give me a menu to that place even though
I wish I would have got one yesterday
because there's something else I would
have
ordered did I tell you about this I
don't think so so let's cut through the
chase we're not going to talk about what
I ate I ate dick I had a salad and
soup and and uh and some pry
camar half yeah you said you said you
ate that yeah so I'm sitting there and
all a sudden my buddy comes in now
whenever I go to this place I always
bring up some loose joints some laughing
gas I bring up some uh uh
ABX for the main dude he loves the abx's
he'll pop in his mouth and chew
on him with no water I know two people
who stick them in their mountain and
just grind on them Jes chist blast in
their mouth I never seen nothing like
that and my whole 20 years together we
never I never popped one of
those things in my mouth I think I was
faint oh yeah those pellets you
put in your mouth the th s Gru
ones and I'm sitting there and I think I
had a mushroom
barall but we start talking and we start
talking about Edibles and he's telling
me he smokes that that you and I
smoked Outside The Improv with my
brothers up in San Francisco the dabs
the dabs and I almost I
almost fainted that night on Melrose I
can't take I was an old man already
and they G me dabs and
stuff so he's telling me he smokes all
these dabs and he goes if you want I'll
give you some I go well what am I gonna
do with dabs my wife sees a pipe it's
over I don't need that in my life
so the next thing you know he's telling
me you got any Edibles I oh dog I got
some edibles but they're not the ones
you play around with okay yeah it's like
come on dude I've done this I've done
that I've know this guy for 40
years I got him by 10 but I've known him
since he was a kid I mean a
kid Le all right let me see if I
have the messages he was sending me last
night
all right oh here we
go I hit him up at 1:40
a.m. and he put
sleeping when I called him he text me
back and then when I woke up I I
answered at 9:07 but he sent it at
6:15 and he just kept writing wow wow
wow wow wow
and it's one of those Uncle Joey
Classics because I felt like he was
doubting me so I showed him the
container he looked at it right I had
one of these I showed him the
ABX he looked at
it and he's like I don't know and I go
what do you mean you don't know I go
take one he goes well give me two of
them I'll take one now and I'll give one
to one of my friends I got do what the
you want so right there in front of
me he pops his little
ABX I love him to death and I see him
drink his club soda and we're
talking and I I gotta go I give him a
big hug I take a picture of one of the
guys at the bar I get in my car and I
decide I told you I went down to North
bergon the whole thing
anyway I'm not even on route
three and this is already
texting me dog what's in that thing
right and I hit I call him back you know
he text me but I call him back and he's
like dog I can't stop bouncing around
what's in that stuff I'm confused like
go listen you wanted to see the devil
sucker you're going to see the
devil all right and he's I can't
believe it I'm just gonna go home so
when I got home I was concerned I called
him back talking about his
dog he's like man I don't know if I can
pass out because my dog Lola or whatever
the it is this was 6 in the
afternoon 6 o'clock in the evening why
are people still doubting you with
this guy this went back and forth till
about 10 and then he went radio
silent he just went kaputs I didn't hear
nothing else he blacked out too oh my
god when I talked to him this morning he
said he woke
up he pissed and he went right to the
refrigerator he ate two bags of
pretzels he told me what he devoured I I
forget I'm too high right now he
said a cheesecake earlier he said he ate
an entire cheesecake a whole cheesecake
from Costco and something else
guys those cheesecakes from Costco are
big and he made a protein shake
that's right he started off with a prot
te Shake he thought that would tame the
lizard not this ABX you
go deep the other day I made a
concoction Monday night that's what
happened she reminded me that I ate I
didn't know that I ate Monday night
that's what really happened it really
wasn't a blackout I probably went
upstairs and a th000 milligrams hit me
Lee and the next thing I'm fake I'm
making a uh Mort
sandwich on this Ry baklava bread with
arugula and spicy uh crust red pepper
and a slice of avocado nice dog who you
think and I toast the bread come
on Lee I'm just trying to stay alive
here you know what I'm saying I don't
know what apoc bread is I don't know
either I don't know what they call it
some bread from over somewhere CH chick
tick I I don't know it's just good I put
avocado toast on that in
the morning tremendous no egg you people
put the avocado and then the egg I'd
have a heart attack just give me
the avocado put a lot of crush red
pepper put a little olive oil on that
Savage smoking you know what I'm saying
so what happened to your buddy what
buddy the guy who you gave the anal
to I called him today he asked me a
bunch of
questions I said listen don't worry
about I go go on Netflix and
watch the thuru special that's the same
thing I gave you call me like five hours
later he's like what's your friend's
name and what is it on I go Netflix go I
ain't got Netflix I'll look it up on
YouTube and that was it I haven't heard
from him he's Mia again I won't talk to
him till during the week and he hangs up
on me all the
time like whenever the conversation
always ends we'll be talking like me and
you go later
we just talking about a restaurant chick
what the
that seems like something you would
do what's that that seems like something
you just hang up you know what bro we
grew up together so I told you it's kind
of but man we'll talk three times in the
night and he'll just hang
up are you coming that's a great move
come on dog sometimes you gotta hang up
on a well anyway I got no
winners Kansas City's about to play
the Jets I don't know what
they're giving six and a half or
something listen you never seen a bookie
with a part-time
job I'm gonna go it was good to see you
my brother good to see you buddy we
spoke every night we did a check-in
every night after each comedy show I
think Saturday was too late I was up
though I was up last night I was so
blasted I was up last night it
was a it was a time difference yeah we
like yeah we talked every every day
about it wow no but we spoke at night
about your comedy and how you
uh you know felt then Josh zoomed with
me and he praised you and then this
morning I got pictures of you with you
and Colleen and so oh yeah she sent
you those yeah no and the dirty ones too
with you kissing up on her and rubbing
kiss up on her little
just because it's a Jewish
New Year you're out there kissing women
in omah Nebraska trying to tell me the
the Ruben was inventing in the
brass that's what she said it probably
was but it well see you learn something
you and then listen like you go there
now and you might not go there for two
or three
years until you're ready to go
you know and then you become
regular there and then you do it for
about two years and then one day you go
it I'm doing the clubs I want to do
and that's one of the clubs that's a
club when you want to disa appear if you
want to go up there on Thursday you
disappear and you uh nobody
knows nothing for three days if you want
to disappear again you go to Wise Guys
in Utah you just disappear there for
three days ain't nothing going
on there you go you take some notebooks
you take some reefer you walk around the
desert you get bit by a snake
and you come home with a little
ey patch that's it I've heard I've never
been a wise guy I've heard good things I
like tremendous these are all little
clubs that there's no mus no fuss you do
one two radio shows on Friday and you're
out of there dog the community is grown
around comedy and these a bunch of Comm
you know I can list 10 of those names
Utah look what's going on in Boston the
explosion up there in a different way
the old guys are moving on they're
getting old we're getting old the young
guys are taking over with a new brand
the comedy and whatnot did
anybody see Sam J's new special I
haven't se I saw that is that what
because she had one on HBO there's one
on Netflix now right is that it I don't
know I watched the one on Netflix last
night last
night I was watching the
honeymoon was with my daughter we were
all excited cuz Mambo Mama Loves Mambo
was on at 12:30 we were all jazzed up
already we made chocolate egg creams
last night she dipped the 's chocolate
donut that oh yeah yeah I
said drip the chocolate not for me
that's diabetes Central I a got time to
do that money jumping jacks before I go
to bed so we came down here it was like
10 to 12 Seinfeld was on WP IX I'm
sitting there with her and
midnight comes it's another episode of
Seinfeld the look on her face it was
like the look on people's face then they
shot Kennedy in front of the TV
what F to do you know what I'm saying
like he's bringing hope to the world or
something and
uh we wanted to kill time so I know Sam
J I know Sam J from Boston I think
that's why I met at one of the clubs he
was my feature act like once or twice oh
yeah I spoke to her when she lived in a
small place and then when she came to La
she came to The Comedy Store great girl
I knew was a matter of time she had a
great look and she spoke the truth oh my
goodness this special is the
most unwoke thing I've seen in
years even I mean I had like I was in a
I was in a position where my daughter
was there and she was saying some
that I was like I can't have my daughter
hear this she was watching it
huh you let Mercy watch it too I thought
it was she's going to talk about black
issues don't know I don't know I didn't
think she was taking it like that she
did a bit about midgets I was
rolling for 10 mid minutes she
said that she watched the show where
these
seals go on top of
these ice things and then the ice things
grow and they they start getting cold so
they they commit suicide they jump off
the thing and you hear the audience go
something and she goes why should I give
a about that I mean she just
dropped some real knowledge suck my dick
when she said suck my dick Mercy nearly
folded into the couch I love it you know
what it was me at that age listen to
Richard Pry and it shows you where
people take it sometimes it's not like I
have that on constantly I put that
on once a month with somebody who's
doing something special I I didn't know
she was doing something that
special but the 15 minutes I saw she did
a great job and she didn't play by the
rules I love I haven't seen I'm
gonna have to go I love watching new
specials and I'll leave you with that my
little friend what do you got
week tan this week Thursday night I'm at
Elissa brewing in
Connecticut and that's this week that's
it no open mics oh yeah I got open mics
every day well oh I got I'll be in
Maine doing open mics the next couple
nights Wednesday I'm in uh Wester and
moon socket again then Thursday in
Connecticut and what about the weekend
what are you gonna do Saturday I'm going
to see it's funny you just brought him
up I'm going to see
Seinfeld there you go you Tak I've never
seen him live you taking Mom yeah yeah
she's exced maybe
91 really in New York no I saw him in
Denver oh very excited to see him I
was a fan of the
show it was funny like he really
enlightened me I was a big fan of his
really from his work on the Rodney
Dangerfield young comedian special and
what he did with all those top-notch
Comics Seinfeld was very good in that so
I always kind of liked them I like the
thing I went to see him he was
very he was different than what I
expected I was going to see but still
very good at it he's really good
at what he does you know now what he
does I don't know really I see him on
he's drinking coffee in a car
with somebody on Netflix I I think I
watched one episode ah so enjoy but he's
one of the masters from Old School I'm
excited this month I'm seeing two I'm
seeing him and I'm seeing Chappelle in a
couple weeks okay what you seeing
Chappelle at the B the garden the garden
and then you know what actually in
November I'm seeing Burr so I gotta like
good good month where bur Foxwoods okay
because I know he's at Madison Square
Garden and Dean Del is opening
from at Madison Square Garden yes that's
awesome for Dean yes Dean's a bad
just like you
you're moving up and Dean's
moving up doing the garden who's better
than Dean Del and nobody even looks at
the kid you know he deserves it
he works hard yes he's gonna fall into
something they all do D they all do they
all fall in work Prevail uh hard
work always prevails don't
believe the hype huh stop it that's it
I'll see you guys next week
have a great weekly hit me up
during the week and let me know what's
cracker lacking love you buddy all right
love you too and now for a word from my
sponsors Jack have a great
[Music]
week
thank you for listening to the check-in
I want to thank Lee and I want to thank
everybody who puts this together but
before we leave I got to talk to you
about something the holidays are coming
thanksgiving's coming listen it's a
beautiful thing people come over your
house and you bust out one of these
freezable freeze pipes that I got the
company the freeze pipe makes a
tremendous bong if you're sick and tired
of inhaling that smoke having coffin
attacks and taking little baby rips then
it's time to make a switch why Uncle
Joey I tell you why because every freeze
pipe comes equipped with a FR a
freezable glycerin chamber what are we
talking about here it cools the smoke
down
by 300° so do me a favor check out the
freeze pipe.com right now the capital
free pipe.com right now and I'm going to
get you 10% off your entire order it's
American owned for over seven years
affordably priced and Shop the smoothest
pipes bubblers bongs the freeze pipe.com
use code Diaz for 10% off your order I
also want to thank dra Kings I also want
to thank betterhelp.com I'll see you
next week stay black I love
you Lee stay black I love you